oh i got a new dock for your ass netflix
just dropped it
what is it it's the mob versus new york
unless they've been watching it oh
you've been watching oh yeah and
the rico act i remember it very well but
the the rico act i always thought it was
because they give
which it is to your point they gave them
longer sentences yeah so guys started
snitching
but what the rico act did is so let's
say you're the head mob boss
and i'm uh i'm the underboss and then
chin's the captain
and cat's a street soldier and we
they keep catching kat and she's running
her racketeering and
you know shaking people down and they
catch her and she goes to prison for a
year
but they're like dude what the [ __ ] we
keep catching these guys we can't touch
the boss they never talk about they
never deal with it
they we can't never catch them because
they're not doing the dirt what can we
do so that this professor i think from
columbia
or cornell came up with the rico act
he's like no no
you gotta try try them as a group
so you might catch that foot soldier but
that foot soldier is getting orders
from the boss and that boss should be
responsible so he's getting orders from
somewhere
so by them coming the crime you can go
after the bot as a group now that's how
they went after the five families
that's the rico act yeah that's right
it's racketeering you guys are
organizing and trying to
[ __ ] not then they have they have a
guy on there spoiler alert with
mafia versus new york in three two one
suck it they have a guy in there who his
whole job was to bug
the mop to bug the entire mafia so their
houses their cars their phones
dude this guy had some balls because
they started on purpose messing with
this he was like uh he was high up in
the
in the mafia they started messing with
his tv so it started flickering
they made somehow they figured out how
to make it flicker so he calls the cable
company
and they route it so when he calls it
goes to the fbi
awesome and like yep we'll have someone
there tomorrow more at 9 a.m so this
dude
doesn't know [ __ ] about cable gets the
suit comes in
and he's like trying to mess with it and
why he's doing he put in a bug
and then of course they stopped making
it he was all fixed the guy's like right
he said it was scary because the
the mafia dude you were scared the guy
was a killer the whole time watching
them yeah
but they put the bugs in there and then
they put the bug in the head guys house
and they were because it was hard for
them to decipher what they were saying
it's kind of muffled you know
it's this is the 80s man late 80s early
80s so it's all like
mumbled and then they could hear him you
know like oh
oh i'm like what the [ __ ] what is he
doing oh he's [ __ ] his maid
non-stop he's made non-stop yeah
jesus christ and they flipped her to be
uh uh chatty kathy
she didn't know she was stupid she's
like i keep talking to this guy jake all
the time no
jake who like this guy jake asked for
pictures and
asked about you and like and you talk to
him
yeah like no more talking to jake you
[ __ ] don't talk to jake yeah but
there's a lot of
video of him just balls deep in this
lady well
these guys well his wife went to like
the grocery store of course yeah but
it's funny because
you know these like they're like you
know they're like square fbi guys like
what is that
yeah oh oh oh i'm like is he wrestling
they're like trying to figure out the
maid is he trying to fix the toilet
what's happening he has the maid they
figured it out
and they said one guy to listen to it
all the time that brought him all they
had to listen to hours and hours of
tape so one guy's just like oh god here
we go again that's that brought him down
though all that
that grit that that sort of [ __ ] work
that brings you down that detailed [ __ ]
work
well they got them you know that's when
they were able to build the case because
they got them
confessing of all of it and they didn't
realize how much they controlled
the unions man they controlled all that
which runs everything they can shut the
country down
that's what he said he phone call he
said with the unions everything we have
you know we have access to three million
people so if we say
stop doing what you're doing in protest
three million people going to protest in
new york
we have that power yeah crazy that's
amazing man and they brought them down i
remember
i remember when they set that fulton
fish market on fire because giuliani was
like i'm breaking you guys up
and they set it on fire i remember when
it's like my friend i told you he had
a restaurant and he goes uh the garbage
guys come by
and he goes you know i'm good with you
guys i'm going to shop around they go
go ahead yeah go ahead yeah he's like i
couldn't get anybody
every guy was like not my area you got
to go with those guys like i know but
they charged me he goes that's the price
bro
well now it can put a jukebox so my
friend's dad jimmy burke owned a uh
a bar there'd be a jukebox and every bar
there's a jukebox
and at the end of the day or at the end
of the week a guy come in
and take money out and that'd be it and
you'd on the bar and you go
hey dude that's it's in my bar that's my
[ __ ] bar
and they'd go oh yeah but that's
our spot yeah we don't we own that yeah
and that was it
they have so many rackets so many so
many
there's so much death back then too in
the 80s like the death
well what's weird is you know the the
murder rate in new york has never been
higher until now
oh i know so hey thanks to blizzard in
1997. yeah good job de blasio you know
what's great about de blasio he goes
also
we're not going to clean up graffiti
anymore it's a it's a form of expression
so we're just he wants something no more
back to the age so no more 70s so no
more
if you paint a mural the giant dick all
good baby yep
it's it's a freedom of special he's
literally made this he's also associated
we can't
paint over he also believes you should
tax anybody who makes a lot of money 75
of their income he's so [ __ ] dumb
he's so dumb that guy how do you know
look at the murder rate
the highest has been since 1997. how do
you not go man maybe we're not doing
stuff right with the
defund the police and the moves on how
quickly people start killing each other
too
as soon as you don't have law order oh
last one then we'll move on how about he
goes
you can only protest if it's for black
lives matter any other protest you will
be arrested
yeah well that's not constitutional no
it's not allowed how crazy is that
how nuts is that he's a tyrant that's
what people realize
he's a liberal he's a tyrant he can say
whatever you want he's
this is this is a not a good guy never
has been they knew
when people vote him in but new york if
new york is going to vote him in then
that's what you get
we got newsome too it's like both states
on fire
yeah what are you going to do well these
sports you've got to vote and you've got
to
educate yourself you've got to vote
you've got to realize
but you want to stay and fight too
because there's stuff worth fighting for
that's the problem you know so much of
it is do you do you move away and run
away or do you fight
it's hard now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue okay what's gonna
happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been
she was doing disrespected